מתי עד שלא באתי לעבוד איתם בידיים לא
הבנתי את זה
כל הכבוד באומץ עבודה ספציפית וכולם
מבינים את קיות פסיכית זה ציונות הם היו
תשמע אחי עוגודה של בר החבר'ה של ה הלוג
אמרו לייצאתם אותם תקשיב כאילו כבר היינו
חבר'ה מילואים כאילו יש פליי הלאה כן טוב
ככה
הנה מחיית כף אחי בגובה פחל של
מחיית כף גובה פנים ככה
אני
כן
שם תפקיד
התחלנו
כן
יאללה אה רועד א מגד א
רועד שם צמד לפה
דבר רק לג
אתה מדבר אליי
יאללה עוד פעם התחלה
כן שם שם משפחה מלא תפקיד
נתחיל
כן
אחד כפיים
לא פסיק
יאללה א רועד רועד בלוס בן נו צריך סליחה
מהתחלה לא בן מה זה קירות
יאללה טוב מהתחלה התחלנו
כן
אה רועד בלוס א מגד שקט חטיבת גיבעתי
אתה נכנס לתפקיד בתוך דוד בתוך לחימה
בתוך הלבנון מחליף מגד מאוד מאוד מאוד
ותיק שמחזיק את כל ה את כל הגדוד גדוד
שעבר המון היה עם 401 לאורך כל עזה קצה
לקצה עבר לחטיבת גיבעתי נכנס באובי הקורב
באמת אחד הגדודים החזקים שראיתי בלחימה
מאוד נעול מאוד חזק אתה בעצם מגיע לתוך
האירוע של נקרא לזה של הזאוטרים של
הסילבסטר של ה של הליטני מה שנקרא אתה
נכנס
א' תחושות לכזאת משימה מורכבת וקשה. ב איך
אתה רואה את הגדות? יופי. אז אחד אני באמת
זכיתי להחליף את לוריה, חבריה טוב א ואחלה
נשק ומפקד מהחטיבה. אה מחליף אותו,
מתחלפים בחוץ מיד לאחר טקס החילוף. אני רק
מתאר את זה במשפט שתבינו על מה מדובר. מיד
בסוף הטקס קפק שיחת פתיחת מגד קפק אחד
ומפגש ראשון עם הגדוד הוא בלבנון ישר
לעלות לנמירים של של הגדוד ולדהור קדימה
לחצות את הליטני לתקוף את את האוזאותרים
זאת שרקיה משם המשכנו לו עוד משימות
נוספות ברכס הבופור איך אני רואה את הגדוד
אני רואה את הגדוד שנלחם הרבה גדוד מנושא
אה
אני ניסה הרבה להגיד את המילה שחוק אבל
גדוד שעבד קשה מפ פי מינוסים נלחמו הרבה
אבל אמרתם צריך להכניס משהו אחד נוסף זה
רוח
להחדיר בהם עוד רוח וממשיכים המשכנו קדימה
ותקפנו עוד חוצים טליטני זאת פעם ראשונה
מת שיצא התקפה עם הגדוד לאחר מכן רכס
הבופור ועבודה על השמדת תשתיות ואויב ברכס
עצמו
אתה נכנס אחרי שהיית בתקופת העזה בזמנו
סיימת פול אתה בא ונפגש עם קרקע שאף אחד
לא ריגש איתה
בתקדת 98 נסגה אחורה בזמנו אנחנו נכנסים
לליטני לזוטרי וכל הבלאגן
איך אתה מעקל את הדבר הזה בתור מגד שעכשיו
נותן למפלה עם הנמרים עלי רגלים איפה זה
פוגש אותך אותך
אחד תמיד א כאילו הליטני עצמו היה סוג של
קיר כזה במחשבות שלנו כעם ישראל כמדינה
שמשהו רק א נראה משהו דמיון בכלל שלא נגיע
לשם ולא נחצה אותו באמת
דיין את הדבר הזה הרבה באימונים,
בתרגילים, אבל עד שאתה לא פוגש את זה
פיזית בשטח, אתה מבין את האתגר של שהדבר
זה אתגר הקרקע והאויב, אתה לא מבין מה
מדובר באמת. אומר, בגלל שאתה מגד חדש, זה
פעם ראשון שאתה פוגש, זה המופע הראשון שלך
מול הגדוד א ברמה שאתה אתה נהג נמר שלך
כמגד, אמר לך אלן שלום, אני שרל, נעים
מאוד. אני אני נהג נמר שלך מגד, בוא תעלה
זה הנמר. אני לא הספיקתי לראות את הנמרים
שלי גם לפני צריך להגיד פעם ראשונה שאני
פוגש את הנמרים של הגדוד זה בתייבה ו
זכות חלום זה חלמו של כל מפקד פעם ראשונה
שיוצא עם אגדוד לאיזה משהו זה חציית
אליטנים והתקפה של א 14 קילומטר וציר
העררי מה המשימה הראשונה שלכם
יופי המשימה הראשונה נכנסים לטייבה בתצורה
רגלית עושים שם הגנה במשך לילה א משם
התקדמנו קד קדימה לתקוף את היעדים נבחרים
בתוך זהות הרשרקיה כמובן חצה את הליטנה
ויצא להתקפה ותוקפים שם א אתורי אוהב
נבחרים וממשיכים להעמיק בפשיטות בתוך בתוך
הכפר עצמו
איך הגעתם לז
יופי מגיעים לזוטרים
מגיעים לזוטר בבסיס נמרים מה שהסברתי
מקודם זה זה למעשה המופע הראשון שלי המופע
השני שלי לאחר הטקס חילוף שיחה פתיחה
המופע הראשון שלי מול הגדוד הוא חצ ציתן
תקיפת הזאטרים מגיעים לזוטרים בצורה רקמה
על בסיס 20 כלי רקם 24 יותר נכון כלי רקם
שמתוכם טנקים דינייינים נמרים ויוצאים
להתקפה לדבר הזה מפרקים שם א הכל ומתבססים
בצורה טובה
מה המשימה בתוך הזוטר
יופי המשימה בתוך הזוותרם לתקוף בלכבוש
יעדים נבחרים לפשות על תורי אויב א נבחרים
החל ממפקדות החל חל ממחסני אמלך, תשתיות
אויב ומפרקים את הדבר הזה וממשיכים גם
להעמיק גם בתוך הזאטרים עצמם כן הזוטרים
זה רכס גדול צריך להגיד הוא מוכר משני
כפרים אנחנו מצליחים לתקוף את הכפר הראשון
יחסית בצורה מהירה זהיותר שרקיה זהותר
המזרחית ובוחרים להעמיק עוד קדימה כי
בשביל לנצל הצלחה ולתקוף גם את זותר אל
גרביה וגם שם פושטים ותוקפים את כל הכפר
וסורקים בית
עד עכשיו הכל סבבה סיפרת סת שעלית על הנמר
שנפגשת אותו פעם סיפרת שעבדת עם חיילים
שהיית פעם הכל טוב הכל יפה פתאום על זהרים
חטפנו פתאום אלם כל צהל אלם טקטי
ודמות רחפנים עם סיב הדבר הזה תופס אותם
ממכסיים למטה צריך להגיד אני הייתי עם עם
קחצר והיינת
ודיברנו על זה ואומר אני מכיר את האיום
מופעה שנתיים מרוסיה אוקריינה לא נגענו בו
אומר את זה חד משמעית לא נגענו בו הדבר
הזה בעצם מביא מעמיד אותנו באיום שאין לו
מענה ברמה הפרקטית. עזוב עכשיו את
הקומבינות שיצאנו.
א' בתור מגד שיש לו חיילים על הראש. מה זה
איפה זה תופס אותך? הדבר השני זה
עד איפה וכמה אתה מושך את החיילים
להתחיל לעבוד בצורת הגנה שהם לא הכי עד
עכשיו. האין ערך רשתות? האין ערך מרווחים
מטורפים גם בתור חוליות? תרחיב לי.
יופי. אחד באמת זה איום שראינו אותו רק
בסרטונים ושמענו עליו הכרנו שזה קיים
בעיקר באמת מרוסיה אוקראינה שגם ניסינו
ללמוד מזה קצת בקורס בקורס הפיקודים שלנו
בצורה כזאת ואחרת באמת פוגשים את זה בפעם
הראשונה באירוע הראשון המבצעי הראשון הם
נפגעים אצלי בגדוד תחת פיקודי זה יורה
מרחפן יורה מרחפן נרחיב עליו בהמשך שבאמת
א גם מאבדים את הדוקטור של הגדוד הוא א
נופל לנו שם מרחפן שפוגע בן המר שלו עם
כמות נפגעים גם גדולה ואנחנו בהתחלה באמת
מבינים מה מה זה האיום הזה באמת א ואנחנו
מתחילים א לעשות חשיבה בתוך הגדות כי
אמרנו הפתרון צריך לבוא מאיתנו ולא לחכות
לאף אחד כזה ואחר שפתור לנו את הבעיה
המבצעית הזאת מתחינת מודת בדברים הטקטיים
קודם כל מתי מתקדמים האם זה ביום האם זה
בלילה באיזה צורה איך מחלקים חיפוי פועים
א החל מפקל צופי שמיים שמגדירים באמת יש
צמד לוחמים כל זמן נתון שהם בתוך הכוח
צופים שמיים מתחילים מהדברים בחלקתנו לא
מחכים לאמצע לטכנולוגיה כזאת ואחרת אמרנו
מי שינצח את זה רק המשמעת המבצעית שלנו
ואנחנו א בידיים ומתחילים באמת לעשות מספר
פעולות החל מהחיפויים שאנחנו ממקמים
ולמידה שאנחנו מפתחים תוך כדי ומחזקים את
השריר הזה בשביל להתמודד עם האיום הזה
פה אני נוגע עכשיו בנקודה דה שהיא לשמה
אני חותר
אירוע הסילבסטור מה שנקרא אירוע של
הדוקטור הם עשו את כל מה שהיה צריך על פי
הפוקים של פי הנעלים שנה היו מדפים סגורים
הכל כמו שצריך על הזמן ברמה הכי גבוהה שיש
כאילו כשבאו לתחקר אמרו מה המדפים היו זה
מה הכבש היה פתוח הכל היה ברמה הכי הכי
מטורפת שיש
נפגעו חזק חבל על הזמן
אני בכוונה לא הולך לשלב הבא שאתה הגעת
אני רוצה שתדבר רגע על הסיפור של האירוע
של הדוקטור לפני שאתה מתחיל לפרט על ההמשך
אני רוצה לשאול אותך שם השאלה בכוונה אני
מגיע לנקודה הזאתי
תחיל לדבר על האירוע
טוב אה אירוע של הורי דוקור סרן הורי
סלבסטר זכנון לברכה זה הקרפק הרופא הגדודי
א שבו נופל מרחבן ונהרג אנחנו מאבדים איש
יקר מאוד לליבנו
אה
סבחת אותי עכשיו איתו עוד פעם מהתחלה
יכול להבשיר זה לא משנה
אה אירוע של אירוע של סרן דוקטור אורי
סלבסטר זכרונו לברכה אירוע של שבו הרופא
הגדודי שלנו איש יקר מאוד א איש של הערכים
אש של הצרת אנשים אה שהיה דמות בגדוד והוא
עדיין דמות והדמות שלו עדיין א הולכת
איתנו גם גם ברגעים האלה שאנחנו מצלמים את
הפודקאסט הזה הוא נפגע מרחפן נפץ שהוא
פוגע בנמר פינוי שלו שהיה שהוא היה נמצא
בתוכו
הרחפן חודר את הנמר ופוגע בו באופן ישיר
והורג אותו מהמקום זה אירוע באמת המורכבים
שהיה לנו בלחימה שבעקבותיו גם הפקנו לא
מעט לקחם זה אירוע באמת שעשינו כמעט הכל א
על פי הספר א אבל זה הופתנו שם שפעם
ראשונה מבינים שהדבר הזה הרחפן נפש צ חודר
את הנמר אנחנו תמיד הרגשנו מתוך הנמר
שידינו על העליונה כי כך היה הגענו עםמרים
לכל נקודה אין יעד ששמנו במפה ולא מנימרים
דהרנו קדימה ליטני חצינו לא פרסנו זחל אחד
לא פין אחד יצא מהזכלים כלום בלי תקלה אחת
מנימרים ומנימרים הרגשנו ביטחון גם בגלל
שהגדוד דיברנו צבר כבר נלחם לפני בעין
הבנשב אלחים השריר שנקרא רק כבר היה חזק
אנחנו אומרים קוראים את זה כמובן בצורה
צנועה וענו אבל היינו חזקים מאוד בנמרים
אבל האירוע הזה קצת כן נתן לנו סתירה כ
פעם ראשונה שהרחפן חודר נמר חודר נמר
ופוגע בדוקטור באופן ישיר והורג אותו
מהמקום א זה יורע מורכב שבו מהתחקור לאחור
גם בתוך המערכות וכו האויב פה משגר
שברחפנים על הכוח זה מה שאנחנו יודעים
לספור גם בעיניים
גם דרך המערכות ואויב פה עושה מערב על
מערב הוא קודם כל פוגע בנמר לאחר מכן מחכה
לבנת הפינוי שמגיע לפנות את את הנפגעים
בתוך הנמר גם פוגע בה לאחר מכן פוגע בעוד
פעם בכוח שמנסה גם לחלץ לבנת פינוי בעוד
רחפנים נוספים וגם לכל הלקוחות הנוספים
שמנסים להגיע לאירוע אנחנו סופרים פה
שברחפנים ב ברצף בהפרשים של דקות כאלה
ואחרות
איזה מספר שבוע שתהליכת
זה השבוע השני
אני רק מדייק פה כמה דברים צריך לדבר
עליהם. שבוע שני לתפקיד
סמגד שלך הולך להתחתן יצא
אתה וקצינג נמצאים
אחרי רחפן שתי רחפנים שנופלים על הכוח אתה
לוקח החלטה להגיע יחד עם הלבנת פינוי
ולהתעסק בפינוי סליחה.
א' מה עובר לך בראש את המגז?
דבר שני, ספר לי את האירוע הזה מה קרה
שמה.
יופי. זה באמת אירוע שתופס אותנו בהתקפה.
לאחר שסיימנו להתבסס בתוך הכפר עצמו
בהתקפה הראשונה, אנחנו מעמקים, מרחיבים את
מרחב ההבטחה שלנו. אנחנו יוצאים לפשיטות
נוספות. זה מלחת הפשיטות שאנחנו פושטים הם
פלוגת אבטר, פלוגת הפלחות של הגדוד. אנחנו
עושים כמה פשיטות במקבל.
ממקמים נמר נמר פינוי שהוא בעתודה לפנות
נפגעים במידה ויונו במהלך הפשיטה אנחנו
מסיימים את הפשיטה מתחילים את שלב הנסיגה
ש שלב קריטי בפשיטה בשלב הנסיגה לא הכל
הולך חלק פושטים תוקפים את היתורים שקבענו
מוצאים הרבה אמלך פוגעים בהרבה תשתיות של
האויב במהלך הנסיגה לאחור רחפן נפץ פוגע
בתוך הנמר פינוי הזה בתוך הנמר פינוי
שבתוכו נמצא הדוקטור
הרחפן חודר את הנמר ופוגע בדוקטור והרוג
אותו מהמקום א אני מקבל את הדיווח הזה
בקשר על פטיש אוויר מה שמקונה
ובוחר ללכת דווקא לנמר של הדוקטור מהסיבה
מאוד פשוטה אומר אין מחבלים אנחנו סיים לו
את הפשיטה ראיתי אתזה שהדבר הכי נכון
עכשיו תעסק בו זה זה הפינוי של א של הרופא
כי אני מבין שהוא נפגע אני מבין מה
המשמעות ש
שלאבד דוקטור באותו רגע ואני מבין שהוא גם
במצב מורכב שם מורכב הוא בתוך הנמר בהתחלה
קצת לוקח להם מזמן לפתוח את הכבש של הנמר
ככ כבש הנמר גם נפגע בעקבות הפיצוץ של
הרחפן אז אני בוחר שהמיקום הכי נכון שיהיה
עכשיו זה צריך פיקוד מלפנים מפקדים מלפנים
לכן לקוח את עצמי את הקצין הגם שלי
מדוערים לי שם מתעסק בפינוי של הרופא של
הדוקטור
מגיעים לשם, מוצאים את הדוקטור מתוך הנמר,
מכינים אותו ללומקה בשביל להתחיל את שלב
הפינוי.
מביא את הלבינה הכלה. בזמן שהלבינה הכלה
מגיעה לאירוע עצמו, אני זה אירוע של
מפקדים מלפנים, כל מי שהיה בתוך האלונקה,
כי לא רציתי שגם הרופא, שגם הלוחמים יראו
את ה את המטפל הבכיר של הגדוד, הדוקטור של
הגדוד במצב הזה. ראיתי שצריך להיות מפקדים
מלפנים. זה תמיד זה נכון תמיד כמעט גירוע
שצריך פה מיקוד מלפנים אבל פה זה עוד יותר
אירוע רגיש
במהלך הפינוי שמאמסים את הדוקטור הלבינה
הכלה עוד רחפן נפץ נוסף א שנופל ממש עלינו
בינינו באירוע הזה הקצינה גם נפצע נפצע א
קשה נפצעים פה עוד שלושה לוחמים נוספים
ביניה הם גם אני בעצמי קצת מרסיסים
ולאחר אה א הפציעות האלה האויב מוריד עוד
דרכפנים נוספים, עוד דרכפנים נפץ נוספים
נופלים בסביבה מנסים א להפיל על כל דבר
שמתקרב לזירה הזאת אם זה כוחות התודה,
כוחות חילוץ, אוהב באמת עושה מערב על מערב
א ציינתי אנחנו בתחקיר שעשינו מבינים שהיה
שם שברחפנים
שמע ראיתי את המשחק של ספרד א צרפת עם
הילדים תפסתי מול המשחק
צרפת בא אנדר
באה חזקה ספרד באה טיפה אנדוג עדיין ספרד
כן הציגה שהמשחק בכוונה נזכרתי בחיים
כשהיית המשחק של חיבויים בקטע מטורף זאת
אומרת ההוא חתו ההוא מגיע משלים ההוא של
ברסה של פעם
מתאן בכדורגל זה לא נכנס לפני ספר באמת
משהו באמת הצגה בדם ראית אני
ספר צרפת
ראית
שמעתי ברדיו כי הייתי בדרך לפה
משהו באמת הביאו שם הצגה פסיכית זה הזכיר
לי כשפשבתי כאילו הרנות היום אמרתי תשמע
דוד שקט ממש המש שלך שם נפצע
אתה צריך להגיד את זה צינג טיילור נפצע
שמגד שלך בחוץ הנה על העולם אתה מגד בשבוע
שני
דוד שקד
ב ב באמת במהלך שהוא לדעתי זה הסיפור פה
אגב זה לא שום דבר אחר
כל אחד לוקח קצת יותר גם אמפין גם מטה גם
כולם לוקחים קצת יותר ומכרפים על הדבר הזה
לא מרגיש מרגישים את הדבר, לא מרגישים את
החוסר פתאום לא מרגישים למרות שכולם דאגו
מה יקרה אני מקבל פקודה להרים כוח ניהוד
כל אחד בדבר שלו לא מרגישים כזה שמק מרגיש
את הכוח של דוד שקט ומפסק לו תעם א עם של
הצורה כל אחד מספר את הסיפור ב אני כל
הזמן חיכיתי שתרים לו דגל אדום לא הרמת
פעם אחת
נכון
מה נסגר
ספר את הסיפור קודם כל את התהליך הזה כי
צריך לשמוע ממך כן תספר מה שהוא אמר בגדול
כאילו מה המקום שלך שמג
ספר תוצאות הקרב מה ההשלכות מה הפתרונות
שנוצרו לא יודע איך עשיתם את זה אני אמרתי
מהצד אמרתי כי ביני מה קורה פה אגב היית ג
עם הקלח והקס אר תקשיבו יש פה אירוע אתם
לא קולטים כאילו מה קורה פה אמרו זה לא
קולטים אפילו אנחנו בשוקים
אז אני במקום שלי קלטתי את הסמך שלך של
המסיע תופס פיקוד על הלמנת פינוי החבר'ה
שלך הנהגים שהם חמודים להעלה
לא יודעים לנהוג מגיעים עם המון ענווה
והחבר'ה שלי מלמדים אותם לנהוג ומאז אין
שום תקלות בכלים אגב עם המון ענווה למרות
שהם חטפו מה שהם חטפו הם היו בהלם שמה חבל
על הזמן תשמע אני אומר לך עברתי הרבה
בשלוש ב1000 יום האלה ראיתי פה אירוע מאוד
מאוד מאוד יפה תתחיל מהתוצאות של הקרב של
האירוע הזה ומה עשו לכם אחר כך את פתח לכם
את הפשות שלו כמג מה שאתה דיברת באמצן לי
את
כן
טוב אה א במהלך
הקרב הזה, מהלך הפשיטה הזאת, בזמן שאני
נפגע, הקציין הגם נפגע, ממ הפינוי נפגע,
הסמגז גם מפקד האגדוד גם היה בחוץ כי היה
אמור להתחתן באותו שבוע
ונפגעים פה באמת כמעט מספרי 1 שתיים שלוש
אפשר להגיד מספר שתיים לא נמצא נפגעים
ערבים ב
נפגע בצורה אחרת
נפגע בצורה אחרת רוב המפקדים אה
לא נמצ נמצאים או נפגעו
ומה שקורה פה משהו שקשה להסביר אותו
במילים אבל זה בעיניי זה אירוע חטיבת
גבעתי שבה כל המפקדים הולכים קדימה ממפים
תופסים פיקוד אה ברמה של אחד המ מ ממפאים
שלנו עולה על ההמר בעצמו בשביל לפנות את
שאר הנפגעים כי המר נפגע מהצ מהרחפן
שהרחפן הרחפנים הנוספים שפוגעים בגדוד הם
פוגעים בלבינה הכלה
והמר שם היה פאנצ'רים היה לה באמת מצב שאי
אפשר לנוג בו ברמה של קובי שעכשיו נמצא
בקורס ממפי עולה בעצמו על ההמר ומפנה
וכולם הולכים קדימה וככה מפצחים את הדבר
הזה שמפקדים הולכים קדימה חל ממפ שתופס
פיקוד על הגדוד ישר מבין שהמגד נפגע ובכור
תופס פיקוד א במקום מ6 סמל תופס פיקוד כל
אחד הולך קדימה בגזרתו
ממפי המסייע ומפי אשר יום בכלל בוחרים לא
להגיע לאירוע עצמו אלא ממפי אשר יום בוחר
ללכת קדימה לצאת עם הטנקים קדימה בשביל
לבלבל את האויב לעשות הסחת דעת אז הוא
בכלל יצא להתקפה על זטר לגרביה בשביל
לבלבל את השאר הרחפנים שהם במרחב כי אנחנו
מבינים שהוא יהיה פה בזה באירוע הזה שהולך
לא רחפן אחד לא שתיים מעל חמישה רחפנים
נכיל רחפנים מה שנקרא אז הוא בשביל לפרק
את הנחיל הזה גם הוא עם הטנקים הולך קדימה
בלי שאף אחד פוקד עליו קדימה דוהר הקשה
מפעיל אש במטרות כפתור אדום על כל המרחב
ומה שמפצח את האירוע הזה באמת אמרתי שיברח
פנים אבל שכל אחד בגזרתו חל מהמכ
החל מהמ החל מהספ הולכים קדימה ומרחיבים
אחריות
כנראה אתה לא רוצה שתספר שנפצעת באירוע
ולא דיווחת עליו אבל בעצם אתה נמצא ממצב
של מספר אחד זה קלאץ' מלא אבל הוא חצי
קלאץ' אין לך מספר שתיים, מספר שלוש תכונה
הפצוע הכי קשה מהאירוע הזה
וממם נפצע.
איך אתה איך אתה מאגה את השורות?
יופי. אחד אני בזמן שאני נפצעתי
א הקשר שלי באמת לוקח אותי, מושך אותי ישר
אה
לאיזה שדה שהיה נמצא שם כי הבנו שיש עוד
נחיל רחפנים א באוויר וראינו עוד רחפנים
נפץ נופלים. אז אנחנו באמת עושים איזה
הסבואה בתוך שדה שממנו ניסיתי להתמקם
בנקודת שליטה על האירוע ניסיתי להקפיד
לאורך כל הדבר הזה שאני לא להציג שאני
נפגעתי איך אני עושה את זה באמת דרך כל
הזמן בקשר מדבר בקשר נותן פקודות בקשר גם
הפקודות האלה לא הכי
חכמות שיש ברמה של הדקה שאתה תפעיל אש א
מפי הטנקים תראה שזה כי אמרתי אם פתאום
המגד לא נשמע הכלו בקשר זה ישפיע מאוד על
הרוח של הגדוד אז זה הפעולה שעשיתי הייתי
בלי נשק כי הרצועה שלי נקראה שם והב שלי
אף מההדף של הפיצוץ אבל אם יש משהו אחד
שנשאר לי ביד ואמרתי דרכו אני מפקד על
האירוע מפצח אותו פקודות פקודות שישמיעו
אותי שאני שם שאני נמצא ושהכל בסדר אז א
דרך הדבר הזה דרך פקודות דרך נוכחות גם
ברשת הקשר פיזית בשטח לא כל כך כי היה
הרבה בלאגן והרבה עשן אז לא רואים אחד את
השנה אבל אמרתי אם קולו של המגד שמפקדים
היא שמה בקשר
בקול של רוח רוח שבוה ממשיכים קדימה ככה
אני מצליח להרים את הגדוד ממשיכים לדהור
ולא לא עוצרים לא עוצרים עד שע עד הסוף
שמע כמה זראה את זה המחת עוד שיש לי פה
מפלצת סבבה אני תקו איזה מכות החזיר לי
שמע כמה זה עצב פסק לכם את התרועה
ס מה שמה כיתה בפור
אני מגיע התחיל לעזור לכם בניד אני קודש
אתם מפוסקים כאילו כבינט מה אני עושה איך
אני מסיים אירוע פסיכי
מה זה הפיסוק הזה ואיך איך אתה מנהל אותו
בסיטואציה הזאתי עם רחפנים
נכון אה צריך להגיד הגדוד באמת היה פרוס
במרחב מאוד גדול החל מנחל הליטני היינו
בשלב מסוים הגדוד היה פרוס מנחל הליטני עד
כפר כפר זות שרקיע עד הבופור עד כפר
ארנון.
א מה שאמרתי פה זה משהו
שמשטרה הרבה על הרבה קילומטרים
פשוט מסיבה שהגדות רצה להיות בכל מקום בכל
מקום חסר כוח בליטני אנחנו נהיה בליטני
אחרי שרקיה חסר כוח כי גולנים מתעכבים
בחילוף שלנו אנחנו לא מפקירים שם נשארים
שם ועד שגולנים מגיעים באמת רצינו להיות
בכל מקום ועד שלא סיימנו את המשימה עד
הסוף לא רצינו לעבור לאשר אחרינו
לא טוב לשמימה
אבל אז גם מפסיקים להפריע לך פתאום אה
שמעת אני גיע פקודה זיה תביא לי את הכיל
האיראני שמצאת
נכון
תרימו טרון לבד מה והוא אומר לך בקשר לא
הבנתי מה אתה רוצה ששטג יעשו את זה מה אתה
טוב מהם
אחד אני אנחנו מאמינים שכל כוח כל דרג
צריך לפתור את הבעיות הדרג מעליו מלמים
שלמחת לחטיבה בעצמה
נותנים לה הרבה משימות העוגדה נותנת
לחטיבת גבת הרבה הרבה משימות ואני הראיתי
את עצמי כמגד כל הזמן שאלתי את עצמי שאלה
מאוד פשוטה וככה אני מחנך את הנשים שלי כל
לראות איך כל דרג פותר לדרג מעליו בעיות
וכן אם צריך טיל דירני קדימה מארגנים כוח
מוסף ושום דבר לא עוצר את הדבר הזה שנקרא
גדוד שקד ולא חטיבת גבעתי ומרכיבים גם
כוחות בתוך בתוך הצקג עצמו בעם כוח הנדסה
עוד כוח יהלום איתנו עוד דוקץ והולכים
קדימה אבל לא עוצרים לא עוצרים היינו באמת
רעבים פשוט לעוד משימות ורעבים לניצחון
ואז הגיע את התק אומרת התחלנו גם בעלייה
לרסופ
האלה עלינו וגילינוך את כל העניין עלטקים
פתאום אתה מוצא שהלוחמים שלך באמצע לבנון
צריכים לשנות קצת משימות חוץ מהסריקת בתים
חוץ מה
כיבוש יעדים מהמרחב הגנה
מבינים שהמשימה עכשיו היא בעצם לפוצץ
להכין את כל הפיצים של התק
מה קורה שמה
יפה אחד אה א פעם ראשונה שנופל לך הסימון
על התק מגיעים לכפר ארנון
א היה שם מנהרה בשם להב שלוש אנחנו
כמפקדים הולכים לראות אותה מזכים אותה
כמובן עושים את הפעולות ההנדסיות שנדרש עם
יהלום סח
ברגע שאתה רואה את הדבר הזה איך הוא נכפר
ומה הגודל שלה כמעט את מגיע עד לקילומטר
והעומק אתה מבין שהדבר הזה צריך להיות
מושמד צריך להיות מושמד
ולא משנה מה אתה צריך להביא לוחמים
ולהשמין את הדבר הזה.
עכשיו אני צריך שתספר לי את זה אבל משפט
מלא. ספר לי על המנהרות ואז תלך לדבר הזה.
למה אני אומר לך את זה? כי אני רוצה אותך
בזמן מסך צריך שתסביר לי את הדברים האלה.
יופי. אה עוד פעם שנייה אתה רוצה שנספר על
ספר לי מה זה המינהרות. מה אתם מגלים בליב
שלוש היה הראשון אחרי שבוע אני שיתפוצץ
שם? אתה מתחיל לחקור אותם. סבבה על על
האירוע הזה. מה זה הדבר הזה? מה זה ל13?
מה זה הדירוג הזה בגדלים האלה ומה מה הופך
להיות היד המרכזי? תספר לי כאילו מה זה
בכלל האיום הזה. סלערה. וואו
יופי. לאחר שאנחנו מסיימים את הקרב
בזוטרים, מתקדמים קדימה עוד צפונה לכפר
ארנון, תבנית ורכס הבופור. רכס על טאר
ורכס הבופור. ברכס אל תאיר ורכס הבופור יש
שם מספר מנהרות שנכפרו במשך שנים. מנהרות
של חסבלה שאפשר להגיד אם אנחנו עושים
הקבלות זה המפקדות שלהם זה דומה קצת לבור
בפצן אובור בקריה זה מנהרות מתחת לאדמה
אנחנו מבינים שיש שם תשתיות פוש הרבה אמלך
ורוב הבחירים של חסבלה נמצאים מתחת לאדמה
במנהרות האלה יותר מזה מבינים שיש גם
בחירים איראנים גם נמצאים בתוך המנהרות
האלה והמנהרה הראשונה שאנחנו פוגשים אה א
כמובן לאחר פעולות הנדסיות כאלה ואחרות
ומזקים וחופרים ומגיעים אליהם זה לאב שלוש
שהייתה בגזרת ה בגזרת הגדוד בגזרתנו אנחנו
מבינים לא צריך לא צריך להסביר יותר מדי
לכל לוחם שמגיע לשם דבר ראשון שנכנסים
למנהרה אתה אומר למנהר למנהרה הזאת צריכה
תוצאה אחת בלבד והיא השמדה השמדה מביאים
שהמנהרות האלה נהלו ורצו לנהל כל מה ש
נקרא תוכנית כיבוש ו הגליל רצו ונהלו
מתכים ויר לעבר שיתחנו ורצו לפגוע
במדינתנו כל לוחם חן מה לוחם א במסיאת בכל
פלוגה שנכנס לדבר הזה שאל שאלה אחת פשוטה
איך משמידים את הדבר הזה איך משמידים
איך משמידים
ומיד מה שאנחנו עושים עם המנהרות האלה
אחרי שאנחנו מתבססים ברכס ברכס הבופור
ובכפר ארנון
רצינו להשמיד את המנהרות האלה. מגילים
אתגר מבצעי נוסף שהקרקע בלבנון שדיברנו
עליה בתחילת השיחה שלנו פה היא לא מאפשרת
הכנסת משאיות אמולסיה בתצורה פשוטה ונוחה
כמו שהתרגלנו בעזה. היה שם יותר קל להכניס
חבלה להכניס אמוסיה.
אמרנו הדבר הזה לא עוצר אותנו. אין דבר
כזה קשה. אם צריך עובדים בידיים, מחדירים
חבלה בידיים. והלוחמים היו צמיעים לדבר
הזה. הלחמים היו הלוחמים היו רעבים למשהו
אחד. היה בהם רעב לשמדת המנהרות והרעב
לניצחון לנצח את הדבר הזה. אז מה שאנחנו
עושים מכניסים באמת על בסיס משאיות אחרות.
ג'ריקנים של חבלה, ג'ריקנים של אנפו.
והלוחמים עובדים גם ביום גם בלילה מתבססים
כמובן עושים רשתות מארגנים את המרחב בהתאם
קיום הרחפנים היה עדיין קיים בשלב הזה
משיגים שליטה מפצעית במרחב מארגנים את
המרחב ומתחילים בידיים
יום לילה מתחת לאדמה צריך ללכת בתוך
המנהרה מנהרה צפופה עם הרבה לחוט בפנים
הולכים בידיים ג'רקנים של האנפו מחדירים
פני פנימה שמים בתוך המנהרה עושים את זה
במשך א בהתחלה חשבנו שזה יקח מעל מעל
משבוע אבל אה לוחמים באמת אמרתי מרוב שהיו
רעבים לנצח ולהכרע ולהשמיד את המנהרות הזה
עושים את זה תוך חמישה ימים בין ארבעה
לחמישה ימים מחדירים 277 טון חומר נפץ את
המנהרות האלה
כתב לי את הנקודות No.